Переповнені лікарні, брак кисню, черги по тести. Це осінь 2020-го.
Тоді Україна пережила перший потужний пік коронавірусу. Наступна велика хвиля була навесні.
І от Україна знову мало не щодня фіксує нові антирекорди: понад півтисячі смертей за добу.
Наскільки готова Україна цього разу до нової хвилі захворювання
і чи провела роботу над помилками після попередніх піків коронавірусу?
Столична четверта лікарня - на коронавірусній передовій з квітня 2020-го.
Відтоді тут приймають лише ковідних хворих.
Ми як увійшли в "ковід", так і не виходили з нього. Працювали всі відділення,
всі лікарі як інфекціоністи і ось мій персонал. Змінилося… мабуть, втома тільки.
Тільки втома. І моральне виснаження. Але працюють…
Нині лікарня заповнена на 85 відсотків. Це більше, ніж у середньому по країні - 60 відсотків.
За словами керівника медзакладу, усе необхідне є. Хоча зізнається:
пацієнтам доводиться докуповувати дорогі гормональні й тромболітичні препарати.
Порівняно з минулим роком побільшало тяжких випадків, каже Георгій Аксютін.
Пов’язує таку тенденцію з новим штамом "дельта".
Цей штам, мабуть, більш агресивний. Він має більшу контагіозність,
і пацієнти, особливо нещеплені, швидше захворюють і переносять значно важче це захворювання.
За словами медиків, ускладнення у пацієнтів з "дельтою" розвиваються швидше,
уже з четвертого-п’ятого дня з’являється дихальна недостатність,
хворому потрібен кисень. До речі, якщо рік тому кисень був у дефіциті,
то нині 96 відсотків усіх ковідних ліжок по Україні мають або підведений кисень,
або концентратор. Принаймні про це свідчить статистика МОЗ.
За даними міністерства, зараз понад 56 тисяч ліжкомісць забезпечені киснем,
рівно рік тому їх було в чотири рази менше. Та попри позитивні звіти уряду,
волонтери в регіонах б’ють на сполох.
У Харкові й Одесі люди не можуть потрапити в лікарню,
бо місця із киснем уже закінчилися.
У жовтні минулого року "Пфайзер/Байонтех" лише завершували випробування вакцини від "ковіду",
яку у світі почнуть використовувати в грудні 2020-го.
В Україні вакцинальна кампанія почалася вісім місяців тому - навесні.
Відтоді лише 20 відсотків українців щепилися принаймні однією дозою.
Хоча за рекомендаціями ВООЗ і судячи з досвіду західних країн, щоб стримати пандемію,
необхідно, аби щонайменше 80 відсотків населення мали щеплення.
Епідеміологиня Людмила Мухарська вакцинувалася вже двічі, але каже:
повне щеплення - ще не привід втрачати пильність.
Вакцинація не захищає на 100 відсотків від інфікування.
Тобто люди вакциновані все одно можуть захворіти. Але хворіти вони будуть у більш легкій формі.
Вони можуть інфікуватися і можуть поширювати вірус, якщо будуть інфіковані.
Тому сподіватися тільки на вакцинацію потрібно, але при цьому потрібно
дотримуватися всіх заходів, передбачених нормативними документами.
Ми всі про них дуже добре знаємо.
Мета МОЗ - дійти до показника у 70 відсотків вакцинованих до кінця року.
Утім якщо нинішні темпи щеплення збережуться, а це близько 800 тисяч українців на тиждень
- до кінця грудня вакцинуються лише близько 40 відсотків громадян.
Люди захищені, які пройшли вакцинацію, але того колективного імунітету,
про який ми всі говоримо і хочемо, щоб він настав, поки що немає.
Оскільки достатньо велика кількість людей поки в Україні не захищена,
оскільки вони ані вакциновані, ані зустрічалися з вірусом, бо ще не перехворіли.
Торік боротьбу з коронавірусом держава фінансувала з так званого "ковідного" фонду.
Витратили з нього 66 мільярдів гривень, з них 40 відсотків пішли на славнозвісну реконструкцію доріг.
13 відсотків - на допомогу по безробіттю, 8 відсотків - на доплати медикам.
У 2021 році з коронавірусним фондом покінчили. Гроші на боротьбу з епідемією
вирішили виділяти через окремі програми у Міносвіти, МОЗ, Міноборони, МВС.
Сума менша, ніж була у "ковідному" фонді: загалом передбачено 36 мільярдів гривень.
Зате, як запевнили в уряді, гроші мають іти на конкретні потреби.
У Мінфіні відзвітували: найбільше грошей станом на вересень витратили на лікування хворих
через програму медичних гарантій, щеплення і закупівлю вакцин.
Фінансуються і "ковідні доплати" медикам. Утім, вони не зупиняють відтік кадрів.
У четвертій столичній лікарні кажуть: ліжок і кисню вистачає, а от рук - бракує.
П’ята частина робочих місць медсестер у закладі - вакантна.
Це проблема всіх лікарень. Розумієте, коли у відділенні хворі досить своєрідні,
це накладає певні напруги на медперсонал. Це не те, що зробив укол,
виконав призначення і пішов. Ти маєш в цей час бути на вістрі атаки.
Поки за словами фахівців, українцям варто готуватися до нової ще гіршої хвилі.
Її особливість - молодь теж буде під ударом.
Цей вірус значно швидше поширюється. Він вражає дитяче населення.
Більше дітей зараз хворіє - значно більше, ніж це було навесні і минулої осені.
І він викликає більш важкі захворювання, точніше більш важку форму перебігу хвороби.
За прогнозом НАН України, рекорд за весь час пандемії - позначку в 20 тисяч нових хворих за добу
- Україна перетне наприкінці жовтня.
У МОЗ пік епідемії очікують наприкінці жовтня - на початку листопада.
Тоді як провакциновані європейські країни - такі як, Данія, Нідерланди, Швеція, Великобританія
- поступово відмовляються від карантинних обмежень.
Для них епідемія вже майже подолана…